os associados na vitrine do pessoal é
muito pessoal vai mudar que tudo muito
bem vindos a mais bela e hoje para dizer
quando é que os vídeos que eu não gosto
de fazer é pedir distrito é tão popular
muito rapidamente até o 26 mil
integrantes aqui em baixo então ficam lá
que eu estava engraçada ser um
campeonato que a equipe entrou no café
do país mas não vai então assunto
treinamento foto implementado muito
básicos um bom futebol porque agora só
grava está quente bola quente e
sustentado é verdade ultimamente tem
andado a fazer muito para quem tem muito
esse tipo de vídeo e agora mais vídeo
que corre ao longo de toda a disputa em
vídeo bola de ferro quente milho pipoca
a ter 44 mil dislikes que eu não tentei
normalmente um bom time e tem muito
comentário acerca do conteúdo isso e que
então o índio [ __ ] confesso que tem
comentários e irrita um pouco mas vocês
porque eu vou sentir está muito tempo
tanto que eu tenho um vídeo do milhão
até o final a que o bope o disco mandava
sempre vem e descobri que
o conteúdo que andava afastado o
julgarem sim eu ainda gosto pessoal
digital
mas na questão do youtube em si é editar
o vídeo não sei o que vai acontecer
estamos nela eu não sei que vai tudo
processo de trazer um vídeo eu não senti
muito feliz em fazer tudo isso é uma
coisa que eu faça 3
só quem é e não quatro anos eu não sei
se vocês quiserem mas quatro anos tem
que fazer a mesma coisa que cansa tipo
psicologicamente mesmo pensei que estava
a entrar em depressão ou pensei que era
muito tempo e não estava fluindo fazer
aquilo a marca muito difícil fazer outra
coisa 4 500 novos agentes continues to
rock tour no canal só para
contextualizar um pouco e vamos mostrar
aqui o meu canal há dois meses atrás e
vou mostrar o conteúdo que andava estar
ok qualquer paixão aqui a mesma metragem
que saiu como evitar um jogador do al 31
perfil da garrafa tem aqui um vídeo que
tem mais gente tomou o papel ímpar é
diferente do tempo inclusive arouca é
depois que tem um blog super rendo aqui
tens em camadas terceira depois tem a
cni também não é grande player no
florete com site mpm pronto não é bem
pois temos um vídeo do ar só depois
então lembrei de tudo rola por aí foi
especial do milhão inclusive eu ia ter
isso que andava um pouco triste mas com
pulso colocando a fazer o que poderia
ter um vídeo do carro em que fui lá
hollande ganhou o carro que possui 1
neste momento pois tem um vídeo ou outro
bem pois é uma merda e portuguesa não
gostei mas depois o time já não possui
mais simplesmente porque já não estavam
lotados em top 10 construções pois
através de publicidade como estava o
jogador lol eu pretendo ser um vídeo
faca 500 super renda no campo nem sabia
que eu ia ter esse impacto do uol já tem
quatro mil vídeos 4 milhões vídeo nilson
e maio já que tem um tabuleiro ouija
depois por brincar com fogo na mão aqui
até hoje todo mundo tem sua um pouco só
que compreender helsinque moc tem um
pouco de perigo envolvido pois há que
encontrar forma imprensa contra iphone
só quer outra vez é que possui um vídeo
super renda então fique completamente
herman cain feliz em ter filho é
qualquer um vídeo de uma pintar uma
mulher queria comer um hambúrguer e das
pessoas deve ser agora só fazer modinha
quente fez um vídeo pintaram dunga tinha
ninguém fez até agora um vídeo super
move ela não é aquele contra a nokia
depois bola de ferro quente contra o
uruguai nesta última semana fez uma faca
quente hambúrguer bola quente
heloísa e tal eu percebo a vossa
preocupação caiu por si mesmo
mesmo votando em quem atrasar duas
semanas atrás quando eu não estava
quente nem a bola quente nem me
perguntavam acabou de fora ninguém vos
onde estavam os jogos ninguém só entendo
uma coisa cai tudo youtuber tem que se
adaptar as modinhas bem que eu tô
fazendo enfrenta ainda não chega em sua
costa olha olha isso aqui é uma faca
eles acompanham não eu passei só que eu
tenho sempre com 25 está entre libertino
a dar destaque ao copiar o mister gay a
fazer com que seu invento pia no youtube
exato foi inventado eu juro convênio de
que fiquem sete turkish 42 completamente
à toa que eu fui fazer nem quer apostar
que eu fiz foi por acaso eu evito
empacar jurídico muito eu não sei porque
a data de sua comparsa 4 contém seu
cérebro embora e quando você tem um
vídeo 14 milhões de visualizações eu
sair agora entendam o meu lado eu e você
vai fazer um período o vídeo foi bem
mais fácil para evitar o vídeo ter muito
mais velho então por que não continuar
só porque é modinha só proteger todos
dizem estar errado só que absurdo dizer
que continuo isso é pública que comprar
na oferta
não mesmo só sei que ela tentou gravar
aqui o que vai fazer agora não quer
dizer que eu não possa voltar a prestar
corpo que eu quero vou para o estado
coloca e vem aí muita coisa continuar
cor não eventuais mais bonito com o
canal o tempo pessoal que gosta de
terror fiquem fazer muita coisa ainda
não é depois mas bem vindo não tem um
pouquinho de derrota vocês só pra vocês
tenham entendido que um lado espero que
também tenha respondido um pouco a nossa
questão de homs vistorias é para já sabe
se tiverem idéias e sugestões quem tem
então por 201 estar ou não meu nem tem
idéia é isso eu não sei pois configuram
caiu acho que te falar algumas coisas
mas pronto eu acho que foi sincero e é
este quem ganha até a próxima